primero 10 años después que han cambiado
en la revolución bolivariana que ha
quedado ese discurso social del chavismo
con Nicolás Maduro ahora en el poder no
ha cambiado significativamente y luego
de diez años del fallecimiento del
expresidente Chávez ellos siguen en el
poder y en buena medida eso se debe al
hecho de que la oposición venezolana ha
cometido un sinfín de errores que los
han anulado como alternativa viable
frente a un gobierno que se ha mostrado
profundamente autoritario pero se
mantiene en el poder y controlan las
instituciones todas las instituciones
gracias a que la oposición absolutamente
de manera equivocada ha estado
convocando siempre a la abstención
electoral ese no es el camino el camino
siempre tiene que ser electoral no hay
una una salida distinta que no sea la
electoral a pesar de las desventajas que
supone competir con un gobierno que
actúa conventajismo frente a una
oposición hoy disminuida entre otras
cosas por su propia culpa señor Ibarra y
cómo ha cambiado esa influencia Regional
del gobierno de Venezuela con maduro
pues habiendo tomado el lugar de Chávez
que era bastante importante en la región
vemos por ejemplo como hoy pues no
varios líderes de latinoamérica no van a
estar en estas conmemoraciones bueno eso
corresponderá en todo caso a la visión
que tenga cada uno de los países en el
en el contexto latinoamericano por
ejemplo el presidente de Chile el
presidente Boris ha sido crítico de
algunas de las posturas que ha observado
el gobierno venezolano así como del
gobierno colombiano del presidente Petro
de modo que no las tiene todas consigo
maduro en el contexto latinoamericano
sin embargo mantiene diría yo bastantes
buenas relaciones con la mayoría de
todos ellos y ahora con el regreso del
presidente Lula en el caso del Brasil
Ellos tienen una estrecha relación desde
los tiempos del presidente Chávez de
manera que el cambio Quizá es algo
significativo porque Chávez tenía un
liderazgo en buena medida
construido sobre la base del precio del
petróleo y la multichechaquera que
cargaba recorriendo el mundo entero no
le ha tocado así al presidente Maduro
que encontró las arcas vacías luego de
una amplísima destrucción económica y
financiera de los recursos del Estado
venezolano en las manos del expresidente
Chávez pero bueno a maduro le ha tocado
le ha tocado más difícil lo cual no
quiere decir que él haya sido más eficaz
y mucho menos eficiente ha sido el
seguidor de las políticas de Chávez pero
sin mayores exigencias de parte de la
oposición que repito ha permanecido
equivocada en el tiempo para desgracia
de los venezolanos Yo soy de oposición y
lamento muchísimo que esas cosas hayan
ocurrido de hecho estamos proponiendo
que haya un acuerdo un gran acuerdo
nacional para acometer los asuntos que
el país requiere de manera urgente como
la recuperación de los servicios básicos
esenciales Y si para ello hace falta
cometer los recursos del Estado hacia el
futuro no hay ningún problema si con
ello podemos acudir a los organismos
internacionales como el Banco Mundial el
banco interamericano de desarrollo la
corporación andina de fomento y el fondo
monetario internacional sin complejos ya
el daño está producido y hay que
corregir el entuerto a objeto de que los
venezolanos en su conjunto tengamos
calidad de vida y sobre todo servicios
las otras reformas que haya que hacer
desde el punto de vista constitucional
para quitarnos rémoras que ella contiene
y que detienen El Avance progresivo de
Venezuela tendrán que ser consensuadas
con todas las fuerzas que estén
representadas en el parlamento en el
próximo en la próxima asamblea nacional
que habrá de elegirse en 2025 Pero antes
tenemos las elecciones presidenciales
del 2024 y un sector de la oposición se
empeña en unas primarias que a mi juicio
van a ser un desastre van a ser un
fracaso porque se han convertido en un
torneo de insultos entre la
multiplicidad de candidatos que por
cierto todos llamaban antes a la
abstención e incluso a una a una
invasión del país eso es un error
garrafal Yo propongo una salida de
consenso
tras un programa de gobernabilidad
acompañable por todos y luego la
escogencia también de un líder de
transición que nos pueda llevar a que el
país transite por senderos de paz sin
venganzas y odios señor Ibarra y cómo
podría precisamente sustentarse una
candidatura de Nicolás maduro con una
pues relativo debilitamiento del
chavismo para unas próximas elecciones
paradójicamente el presidente Maduro que
tiene muy poco apoyo popular tiene un
sólido respaldo dentro de la estructura
de su partido aunque también hay por
supuesto otros líderes dentro de esa
organización cosa que no había con
Chávez Chávez era un líder único en el
caso del presidente maduro tiene otros
líderes que le hacen digamos compañía o
coro sin embargo ellos van a jugar por
lo seguro y el presidente maduro va a
volver a ser candidato Y si la oposición
no hace lo correcto es muy probable que
el presidente maduro a pesar del exiguo
respaldo vuelve a ganar las elecciones
Esas son las paradojas de la política
Pero así es la cosa si no hacemos las
cosas bien vamos a tener un resultado
muy parecido a lo que estamos viviendo
hoy Solo que hay algunos que no se
percatan de que siempre se puede estar
peor